globalization is to a large degree an
economic phenomenon as we explore the
relationship between faith and
globalization it is important for us to
attend to the relationship between faith
and broadly construed economic activity
we're interested for instance in asking
the questions about the condition for
successful economic activity cultural
conditions and here faith religious
traditions play a significant role in a
sense what we are interested in
discussing is a version of the question
that mocks labor the great sociologist
of the 19th century has pursued he has
asked a question about relationship
between one particular religious
tradition Protestantism and the spirit
of capitalism in what way prodigious
Protestantism made capitalism possible
now we can ask the similar kind of
questions question in terms of what kind
of conditions do religious traditions
prepare for the possibility of economic
activity in order to look at this case
we want to examine a country that is
economically booming indeed the fastest
developing country in the world namely
China what is the relationship between
various traditional religions as well as
new religions like Christianity in China
and its intensive economic development
this question is significant in that
sense that it explores the cultural
conditions for human flourishing through
increased economic productivity